one of the most confusing things for a
lot of people about the parameter this
is how it will get bound within
functions when they get past as
callbacks consider this example where we
pass our function to set timeout which
will call the function for us a second
later as you can see we aren't providing
any values that could be passed as
arguments to our callback function FN so
it seems hard to imagine that this code
will work as we want it to let's focus
on those positional parameters first
since they seem a bit more intuitive
what do you expect they're going to be
bound to hint remember that you can't
tell what value a functions parameter
will be bound to until you look at the
specific invocation of that function so
we'll need to go looking for the
invocation of the FN function take a
moment to write out your answer